all right but we're going to be in with
the breaking news from Ukraine a
helicopter crash at least 16 dead this
morning including one of Ukraine's top
cabinet officials and authorities say
that among the dead three children Holly
Williams is following the story for us
that it is still developing Holly good
morning good morning well the helicopter
crashed this morning at a kindergarten
just outside Ukraine's Capital Kiev
there was a fire at the crash site and
Ukraine says 30 people were injured
including 12 children the country's
President Vladimir zielinski said quote
the pain is unspeakable and among those
killed were several senior Ukrainian
officials including the interior
Minister Dennis monasterski President
zielinski's office said the helicopter
was taking the interior minister to a
hot spot when it went down the location
of the crash was the suburb of Bravery
just to the east of Kiev you may
remember it as the scene of intense
fighting in the early days of Russia's
Invasion last year before Russian forces
were withdrew from the area in April it
was reportedly dark and foggy at the
time of the crash but so far the
Ukrainian authorities are not giving any
details about the cause Gail
all right we continue thank you very
much Holly